so I would you have a look at this I
want you to think with me what do we
know about this thing well we know how
frequently it waves up and down or left
to right or whatever it is okay we know
where it starts we know how fast it's
going and what direction it's going in
and we also know where the center is now
this is a bit unusual because there's
something we usually know about simple
harmonic motion something obvious that
hasn't been told to you here why are we
missing have a look take this crap when
we drew it how to be drawn we went from
the center of motion and then the
immediate next thing I asked you was or
how far away can I get from the center
of motion okay how far this thing get
from the center of version EDSA donor
you don't know you don't know now you
could say to it's gotta be a it's got to
be at least two but who says you're
you're starting at an extreme nothing
has told you you're starting a new
extreme for them in fact I don't think I
can be starting an extreme why how do I
know I'm of starting an extra beans
thank you person for light behind you
already had their heads up velocity is
not zero right the velocity is nonzero
at the extremes of motion you
momentarily pause your velocity zero to
stationary point right and then you come
back towards the center so I'm not an
extreme I'm certainly not at the center
because look but they're not the same so
somewhere in between so this is weird
how do I work this out okay now let's
start on farmers what could I do what
could I do to try and work out a
displacement equation from here okay so
i can find em and i can work out I get
that from the period right so I'm just
going to write 2 pi on M equals 6 n
equals pi on three that's good okay but
when i go to write my equation of motion
I know my centre is zero so that's
that's nice that's just 0 out there but
I don't have a number here oh this is
the whole point on this is my problem so
I'm just going to write a
because I don't know do I choose sine or
cosine remembering that it doesn't
matter right doesn't matter you can
choose either but what is more
convenient than the other we know that
sine is better if you start at the
origin and cosine is better if you start
at an extreme add an extreme okay but i
am at neither of those i know i'm not at
the center initially and we just
established that we're not at the either
industries so if you want your foot sign
fine I'll go this site but my point is
like there's no obvious convenient trace
you okay like I'm somewhere between the
center and the extreme so it doesn't
matter which one you can shoot site is
nice it's different here no name less
negatives okay all right what else have
I got here ok so I worked out what the n
wat supply on 3t and then there's
there's some phase that I have to work
out and that's what makes me not start
at the center or not start at the
extremes ok so i have out of 12 unknowns
how I solve them ok good if I get the
velocity equation i can use this piece
information and I've already got a piece
of efficient about displacement so i can
use both of those so that's just quickly
differentiate when i'm going to get
simple chain rule ok so then i'm going
to use my initial conditions right so
i'm going to say initially first let's
do displacement ok so the displacement
equation tells me here's the
displacement equation right so I've got
a sign of what this is initial right
initially initially initially T equals 0
so I've got 0 plus alpha so a sine alpha
equals good ok so sine alpha is negative
2 on a so I don't have enough
information yet but that's ok because i
have another initial condition velocity
right there's my velocity equation so
what am I going to write here
a I on three cause off equals three so I
can say from this cos alpha equal yes I
on a pond that's that's a missy hey
that's a negatory yeah okay what do I do
with this yes triangle okay so i can
draw some triangles right i can do that
if i want to try and this is like the
auxiliary annual kind of situation right
to help me interpret my triangles I can
actually say tan alpha i can divide
through i just have to be careful with
what I get on the other end but you'll
see in a minute I want to worry about
this what is terrible this divided by
this yeah sign our part 1 cos alpha yep
so this lips and then you want okay so
I've got that so therefore alpha is
equal to ok now I'm going to pause for a
moment and say um yes partly tell you
like a second I've got to worry about
the negative language case I've got in a
second I can sort of use that he are
right and work out which one is which I
suppose I would choose a positive
there's no reason why I would choose a
negative a and then I can work out the
signs and go ahead okay but I'm just
going to pause and point out gross right
doesn't that look terrible um number one
that's what I got the alpha and this is
obviously going to be some decimal
garbage out here right in radians and
then after that I've got to work out
what's my other thing hey I've got to
work out my amplitude that's all going
to be terrible it's a binman disaster at
the moment okay so i don't really want
to have to go down this path I wonder if
there's something I can choose something
earlier that I assume that will make all
of this sort of unfold easier for me
right now then plant what about to show
you you do not have to guess you don't
have to predict this will be handed to
you but it's still I want you to see why
they headed to you here here comes the
kick here comes the key to unlock this
right look at my first black line you
see my first black line that's where the
problems began that's where the problems
begin so i'm going to introduce just
like i had over here this like i had
clawed Squared's in my equation of
displacement right I've got a new
equation for you that's going to make
everything really wash here's my new
displacement equation okay all right
yeah you see the question will give this
to so they're not they're not expecting
you to guess that this will be helpful
okay but I wanted to show you guys why
would people even go to I've got any
questions just fine why you do this
mantra fudges to me because when you
just have one sometimes you land in
really disgusting spots I don't want to
do that ok I'm going to rehearse again
same information but I'm going to go
with this ok watch for starters you
already know em right you've already
worked out the period it's a so I'm
going to put that in talk about this
okay now by the way can I just justify
why is this legit what can i do this i
thought we said simple harmonic motion
was only one sine or cosine why is this
okay okay good there's some of two wave
functions still a wave function and if
they've got the same period I can use
auxiliary angle and I can turn this back
into this if I wanted to a dog because
you can see the problems Atlanta but if
i wanted to i can so it's still simple
harmonic motion if you took this you did
x dot and then you did x double dot
you're still going to get minus N
squared blah blah blah okay so it's fine
all right now let's use our initial
conditions watch their to stop right
initially waiting to differentiate sorry
can we differentiate can you give me and
rivet pie on three let me take that out
this is going to turn into cars and this
is going to turn into minus sign oops
mr. C okay did I oh yeah I took now
because I knew you were coming twice ok
so now i'm going to say initially okay
displace me first okay um here we go
here's my here's my displacement
equation right so when T equals zero
what's going to happen on the left hand
side I'm going to have B sine 0 plus C C
cos 0 do you see why this is better why
is it better I don't have to worry about
this alpha guy right that's the whole
point this is the auxiliary angle but it
causes our problems right so let's not
worry about it I'm gonna write that's my
left hand side what is this equal to
stevens to use the minus two initially
my displacements negative to do you
agree yeah so so look this is zero and
that's one okay so i've got one constant
then i use velocity to find the other
one velocity here we go are mrs. pie on
three outside of okay what's inside here
this is T equals zero right so I'll
still got a beak on zero
I've got a minus C sine 0 yes what's
that equal to B what's the initial
velocity it's three thank you the
question told me okay that's zero okay
when we have left here that's one i'm
going to multiply both sides by 3 on pie
so that gives me 9 on five yes have a
look at that x equals okay 9 on pi sine
PI on 3t plus minus sorry minus okay
right so this is why they will sometimes
hand you an equation like this instead
of the one you're used to and what
they're trying to get away from is the
phase shift cuz its course sometimes
right so you do this that's alpha oh you
got well this isn't me showing you
finally alpha is sometimes terrible and
you don't want to do it so that's why
sometimes we use this because no alphas
required